we're grateful to be joined today by the
vice-president thank you very much Mike
for being here members of my cabinet
devoted public servants and angel
parents very important people to me and
to a lot of other people I want to thank
you all for being here thank you so much
for being here we appreciate it thank
you gone through a lot as we take action
to restore our national sovereignty and
defend this nation from criminal cartels
human traffickers and drug smugglers
crime of all kinds coming through our
southern border and other places but
this is the place this is the place we
have the biggest problem by far and I
want to also compliment the incredible
people at border patrol and ice and law
enforcement for the job they've done
they've apprehended so many thousands
and thousands of people that have we had
the proper protection we wouldn't even
have to apprehend they wouldn't be
coming in as president the protection of
the nation is my highest duty yesterday
Congress passed a dangerous resolution
that if signed into law would put
countless Americans in danger very grave
danger the Democrat sponsored resolution
would terminate vital border security
operations by revoking the national
emergency issued last month it is
definitely a national emergency rarely
have we had such a national emergency
therefore to defend the safety and
security of all Americans I will be
signing and issuing a formal veto of
this reckless resolution and that's what
it was and I have to in particular thank
the Republicans strong wonderful people
the Republican senators that were on our
side aren't on the side of border
security and on the side of doing what
they have to to keep our nation safe
they were very courageous yesterday and
I appreciate that very much
Congress is vote to deny the crisis on
the southern border is a vote against
reality
it's against reality
it is a tremendous national emergency it
is a tremendous crisis last month more
than 76,000 illegal migrants arrived at
our border we're on track for a million
illegal aliens to rush our borders
people hate the word invasion but that's
what it is it's an invasion of drugs and
criminals and people you have no idea
who they are but we capture them because
border security is so good but they're
put in a very bad position and we're
bursting at the seams literally bursting
at the seams
what Border Patrol is able to do is
incredible I also by the way want to
thank our military because our military
has been very much involved as you know
and they're putting up walls in some
cases temporary in some cases they were
supposed to be temporary they're so good
that they're better than the permanence
that we're leaving them we've really
nowhere left to hold all of the people
that were captured and we're at a point
where we're just going to have to say
with these horrible decisions that we've
been handed by people that aren't living
in reality that there's nothing we can
do there's absolutely nothing we can do
a bursting at the seams you can only do
so much and the only option then is to
release them but we can't do that either
because when you release them they come
into our society and in many cases
they're stone-cold criminals and in many
cases and in some cases you have killers
coming in and murderers coming in and
we're not going to allow that to happen
just not get allowed to happen there has
been nearly 2,000 percent increase in
border related asylum claims over the
last decade part of the reason is
because our country is doing so well
economically that people are coming up
in droves the vast majority are rejected
but smuggling organizations making a
tremendous amount of money like they've
never made before are using these people
to crash the system our immigration
system is stretched beyond the breaking
point and as I said nothing much we can
do we can just do our job and do it well
but there's a point at which if the
Democrats would would get it would be
able to make a deal literally in 15
minutes we could make a deal or changing
catch-and-release
changing the horrible asylum laws that
are so unfair
changing visa lottery chain migration
these laws are just horrendous I won't
explain them but everybody standing
behind me knows exactly what they are
they're dangerous for our country and
they're inspired by Democrats who have
to change one in three migrant women is
sexually assaulted on the journey north
the border crisis is driving the drug
crisis 70,000 Americans a year are
killed by drugs including meth heroin
cocaine and fentanyl and 270 thousand
people is a number that's so low that it
probably should be used anymore the mass
incursion of illegal aliens deadly drugs
dangerous weapons and criminal gang
members across our borders has to end we
are bringing out thousands and thousands
a year of ms-13 gang members and other
gang members that are just as bad where
they come into our country they're able
to skirt the border come through areas
where we don't have proper wall where we
don't have any wall at all and they get
into the country and they do a lot of
damage in many cases but we get them out
by the thousands and we bring them back
or we incarcerate them the national
emergency I declared last month was
authorized by Congress under the 1976
national emergencies act and they
haven't been too many that are a bigger
emergency that we have right at our own
border consistent with the law and the
legislative process designed by our
founders
today I am vetoing this resolution
Congress has the freedom to pass this
resolution and I have the duty to be
to--it and a very proud to be teller and
I'm very proud as I said of a lot of
Republican Senate
that were with me and I'm also very
proud of the house the Republicans in
the House voted overwhelmingly in favor
of a secure border since 1976 presidents
have declared 59 national emergencies
they often involve protecting foreign
citizens and far-off lands yet Congress
has not terminated any of them every
single one of them is still in existence
and yet we don't worry about our land we
were about other people's lands that's
why I say America first if that's okay
America first the only emergency
Congress voted to revoke was the one to
protect our own country so think of that
with all of the national emergencies
this was the one they don't want to do
and this is the one perhaps they should
most we're joined today by many brave
law enforcement officers including
sheriffs and just people that have been
just tremendous tremendous backers of
law and order which we have to have
we're also joined by friends of mine
Maryanne Mendoza Ken Terry Laura
Wilkerson Sabine Durden and Steve Ron
Beck and I'm going to ask Steve to say a
few words and I'm gonna ask some of the
folks behind me to say also a few words
as to the importance of what we're doing
there's nothing more important as I said
I was elected on a very by him by a very
very great group of American people
millions and millions of people because
they want security for our country and
that's what we're going to have